-Our next guest is
a very funny comedian
you know from his show
"Joe Pera Talks With You."
Tickets for his "Summer in
the Midwest and Rust Belt" tour
as well as his
"Fall Everywhere Else" tour
are available on joepera.com.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend, Joe Pera, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome back to the show, Joe.
-It's crazy to be here tonight,
on the same night as
Katie Holmes.
'Cause my name's Joe
and she played Joey on
"Dawson's Creek."
Also, Joe Biden
is our president.
-What?
[ Laughter ]
That's a --
yeah, that's a real,
real curiosity.
I'm so excited you're
going on this stand-up tour.
And I'm curious,
when you get ready for
a big tour like this,
are you doing a
lot of stand-up to prepare?
-Yeah, doing shows all over
to warm up.
I actually did an anime
convention last weekend.
I was pretty nervous,
but it went well
'cause I opened with the joke,
"I'm so excited to be performing
at this anime convention
that I could scream."
Aarrggghhh!
Like an anime guy.
[ Laughter ]
-Did they -- I mean,
I'm assuming there --
I mean, they must have
just lost their minds.
-They went nuts.
I said, "Sorry,
I can't go Super Saiyan for you,
but that's the best I can do."
-I'm sure they were
plenty happy.
Hey, I'm glad you're
going on tour again
because I'm such a fan of yours.
I am so sorry
"The Joe Pera Talks to You,"
a wonderful show,
it is not coming back.
-No, after three seasons,
they pulled the plug.
Was definitely a bummer.
But my friend
Carmen Christopher...
-Yeah
-...you know him --
he sent me a Steve Harvey clip
off of one of those
alpha Instagram pages.
And Steve Harvey said,
"If a door closes,
don't bang on it,
because if you turn around,
the hallway of life
will present other doors.
And if you're banging
on that one door,
you can't go down
and see other doors."
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-That's, uh -- That will be
a hard line to forget.
-It did cheer me up.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Do you have
anything else lined up
with the open time
you have now?
-Oh, that's why -- Yeah,
I'm really excited to tell you
that Carmen and Steve's advice
was really important
because just the following week,
I got a phone call.
They asked me to be
the next James Bond.
[ Laughter ]
-You're going to be
the new James Bond?
-They needed a different angle
after Daniel Craig,
and now they decided,
"Why not a celibate
American James Bond?"
-Uh-huh.
Now, are you --
I have a lot of
questions about this,
but, um, how do you feel,
you know,
because this is, of course,
as iconic a British character
in fiction there is.
Do you --
How are British audiences
responding to this news?
-I, well, this is
the new -- this is --
They'll be finding out
from this show, I think.
-Oh, yeah.
-I think they're
going to love it.
It's also --
the new angle they're taking
that James Bond
lives in Philadelphia,
he eats prewrapped
Boar's Head sandwiches
for breakfast and lunch,
he's learning to play
the guitar off of YouTube,
and he's very afraid of dogs.
-Okay.
This seems like a really big
departure, not just in casting,
but, you know,
James Bond's whole thing.
-I give them a lot of credit
for trying to refresh this.
-Yeah, you know.
You know what? You're right.
I'm sitting here
congratulating you
when we should be giving
them a lot of credit.
They're the ones putting
their necks on the line.
-They're taking a risk.
But I think, I don't know,
I don't see how it doesn't
work out for everybody.
-Have you done a --
have you shot anything yet?
-It's funny you ask,
because we actually --
yeah, they wanted me
to show the first clip.
-Oh, great.
-Yep.
-From...
-So, is this like a teaser clip?
-Yeah, it was very
early on in filming.
-Okay.
-Yeah, this is --
Hopefully, it doesn't
give too much away.
But this is from the --
James Bond is on his
first mission.
-Okay. And what --
that's all we need to know?
-Pretty much.
-Okay.
Let's take a look.
This is, I guess,
the first look at Joe Pera
as the new James Bond.
Here's a clip of him
on his first mission.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
So I, again,
I end up with more questions
than answers, I feel like.
But -- So it seemed like that
started with a man
spitting out...
-Yeah, yeah, we were shooting,
and he just pulled right into
the camera and spit something.
And, you know, sometimes
the part of filmmaking
is embracing imperfections,
so we decided to keep it in.
-Wow.
-Yeah, so part of
the new angle of
the new James Bond, too.
-So, it seems like --
I, like -- I've always pictured
a James Bond set as really being
locked down and, you know,
not being a situation
where a guy could just sort of
drive through the shot.
-We've actually put an ad on
Craigslist that says,
"Drive through
if you feel like it."
-Oh.
That's good.
You have any more?
I mean, I think, like,
obviously, the appetite is
whetted here, but...
-Yeah, this is another one
from kind of
the middle of the movie.
It might be hard to figure out
what's going on.
But I think --
I think you'll --
I think it will make
sense once you play it.
-Okay.
Let's take a look at another
scene from the new "James Bond."
-So, what's --
what was --
I, um, I don't know
what's going on.
-This is a scene from when
James gets pissed off
that people are littering
faster than he can pick it up.
-I see, yeah.
And he seems like
a broken man in the end.
Because he ends up --
he ends up littering
with the bag of litter.
-Exactly.
-Yeah.
So this is sort of
the "hero is lost"
type moment that happens.
Usually around the end of Act 2.
-Right, exactly.
-Yeah.
-And I don't --
-What's the name?
They always have names like
"Quantum of Solace."
Does this have a title yet?
-The working title is
"James Bond!"
with an exclamation point
afterward.
-To let people know
it's a little more exciting
than the James Bond
you're used to.
-Exactly.
-Yeah.
-And then, yeah, I don't want to
spoil the ending,
but this is the final --
-Final scene?
I feel like that will
spoil the ending.
-Well, I don't know.
I don't know.
Do you guys
want to see the ending scene?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right, here's the --
You want to tell us
afterwards
what we're supposed to see?
-No, just that I actually
heard that they're putting
the full plots in trailers now,
just so that people want to know
what they're seeing.
-Right.
-So MGM can't be too pissed off.
-Okay, great.
Let's take a look
at the last scene
from the new James Bond movie.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So -- the writers -- I wasn't
going to do it at first,
but then the writers said that
there was character development
shown by, in the end, he decides
that he wants to get
chicken, rice, and beans
from a lunch takeout
down the street
as opposed to eating
a prepackaged sandwich again.
-Oh, I see.
-And then -- Yep.
-it's neat to see him
in a baseball hat.
I feel like you almost never
see James Bond,
any of the previous
James Bond --
Did you have a favorite actor,
before you, obviously --
Did you have a favorite actor
who played James Bond?
-They are all so good.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
How about -- There's so many,
you know --
At this point, I don't know if
you can call them catchphrases,
but there's certainly a way
James Bond talks.
You know, all the clips
were sort of absent of dialogue.
Do you, in the body of this,
do you actually speak
and have some of those
James Bondy-type lines?
-Yep. We're working on some of
the classic lines right now.
Everybody knows some of them,
but yeah.
I was doing --
working on the one scene
where I do the big line,
and figured --
Do you want to read it with me?
-The scene with you?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, okay, sure.
So who am I?
Oh, I'm a -- So can I assume --
Oh, yeah, I'm Bartender.
-Yep.
-Oh, this makes sense,
'cause I think we all know
the iconic line
we're working towards.
-Yes.
-'Cause he has
a certain kind of --
I don't need to tell you guys.
There's a certain drink.
Alright. Can I read it?
-Yep.
-Okay, here we go.
Here is your IPA.
[ Laughter ]
What is your name?
-My name is James Bond.
[ Laughter ]
What is your name?
-[ Chuckles ]
Pete Buttigieg.
I'm the Secretary
of Transportation.
-What are you doing
in Philadelphia?
-Oh, just hanging out.
-I've actually been hoping to
see you to tell you my idea.
You should do
a high-speed rail nationwide.
-That is a good idea.
But how fast should it go?
-1,000.
-Joe.
[ Laughter ]
I'm --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not until this moment
have I felt this,
but I'm starting to get
a little worried
about the new James Bond.
[ Laughs ]
-The only way that it could fail
is that we don't get Pete
to play himself.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, that scene would be weird
if you don't get
the actual Pete Buttigieg.
Like an actor
playing Pete Buttigieg.
-It wouldn't --
It wouldn't quite sell it.
-Yeah, that's pretty much
the only problem.
So you shot the three scenes you
brought, and you're rehearsing
for this scene.
-Yep.
-But you don't know
if you have Pete Buttigieg.
-Nope.
-What's the budget
for this movie?
-Mm...
-About 1,000?
[ Laughs ]
-Part of the reason we're going
to try and get Pete
Is that he might divert
some of the funds
from the Transportation
Department
in the James Bond movie.
-See, I'm always worried you
haven't thought this through,
and you always have.
Joe, it's always
a pleasure to have you.
Congratulations again on
this James Bond move.
Thank you so much
for sharing it with us.
Joe Pera, everybody!
For tickets
to his upcoming tours,
visit joepera.com.
Tickets are still available
for Meyer Theater
in Green Bay, Wisconsin,
on August 26th.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."